a missão em áfrica mas tão longe
eu tô família acabar com o câncer de
colo do útero
impossível não sei nem por onde começar
essas foram alguns questionamentos e e
frases que eu vi quando tudo isso
começou
não vou contar um pouquinho dessa
história eu trabalho com prevenção de
câncer ginecológico sou médica
professora e pesquisadora três
profissões encantadoras
mas como juntar tudo isso com o meu
papel nesse mundo de ajudar os outros
eu tenho certeza que cada um de nós tem
diferentes talentos e temos um propósito
como unir saúde consciência é a parte
fácil mas com a ajudar a sociedade
eu comecei meus estudos para o meu
pós-doutorado aqui na uft está em um
grande hospital e hilton no texas chama
md anderson câncer center é um dos
maiores hospitais de câncer do mundo
e lá encontrei minha diretora e mentora
doutora karla chinelo alguém que como eu
acredita em ajudar os outros
diminuir as disparidades em saúde no
mundo e trabalhar feliz e trabalhar em
time
a doutora janela reuniu um grupo de
pessoas com ideais semelhantes e ela me
convidou pra que a gente é pudesse fazer
este trabalho de prevenção e tratamento
de câncer de colo do útero na áfrica e
se a gente olha esse mapa as áreas mais
escuras são onde tem a maior incidência
de câncer de colo do útero em torno de
80 85% das pacientes que têm câncer de
colo do útero das residências e das
mortes desse câncer relacionados
acontecem em países em desenvolvimento
o que acontece é que nesses mesmos
países não se tem nem plano estratégico
para a prevenção de rastreamento
muitas vezes então não existe
rastreamento
assim as pacientes chegam no seu
diagnóstico com doenças em estágios mais
avançados e conseqüentemente necessitam
de tratamentos mais complexos como
cirurgias complexas radioterapia
quimioterapia que infelizmente nas
regiões às vezes também não existe não
será que faz diferença para nós a nossa
área onde nós estamos situados na nossa
saúde
será que influencia área geográfica se
nós somos saudáveis ou não
infelizmente a gente vê que sim que a
disparidade em saúde ela existe e é
muito grande então nós vamos descobrir
moçambique começamos a explorar
moçambique é um país na áfrica
subsaariana em 28 em torno de 28 milhões
de habitantes e é a língua oficial é o
português e nos conhecemos várias
facilidades conhecemos poços de atenção
primária hospitais atendimento dos
pacientes e se formou uma parceria entre
moçambique brasil e os estados unidos a
representados aqui pelo mda nação que
assenta a nossa maior missão é estimular
a aumentar a capacidade local de
atendimento em saúde
a intenção é que a gente consiga começar
a fazer-se desenvolvimento e que no
futuro eles próprios que consigam nos
ajudará a produzir o conhecimento
não adianta chegar lá e sair fazendo a
gente precisa de método disciplina e
time assim sempre acreditem trabalho em
time é de extrema importância quando um
está cansado ou mesmo doente os outros
tem que suprir a demanda e dá apoio
total
quando a gente trabalha em time a gente
uma pessoa ajuda a outra em um grupo
também ajuda o outro
aos poucos a em várias missões tivemos
várias especialidades participando então
um grupo multiprofissional
já tivemos não só a ginecologia que é
onde a gente trabalha o câncer de colo
do útero mas também um colorista
únicos patologista radiologista
intervencionista administradores
engenheiros bioengenheiros e é uma
médica astronauta doutora helen baker
que faz parte do team
nós temos lá em lorca atualmente três
réus
esses elos eles participam de um
programa da mgs que a sociedade
internacional de ginecologia oncológica
e nós somos quatro mentores
internacionais entre americanos e
brasileiros e com esses três favelas
quando nós estamos em loco fazemos todas
as atividades relacionadas ao
atendimento da paciente então até
fazendo os atendimentos clínicos dos
pacientes para cirurgias
entramos nas cirurgias avaliamos as
pacientes nos pós operatórios a e
conversamos com ele sobre todo tipo de
atendimento inclusive como se portar com
as pacientes como se portar durante um
atendimento e assim nessa troca a gente
aprende e a gente ensina
e esses farelos a todas às vezes nós
fazemos reuniões e questionamos como
podemos fazer para melhorar o programa
pra todos nós e eles sabem que o mais
importante é que eles estão ali como
reprodutores do conhecimento eles são
depois eles vão passar outros elas vão
começar e eles vão nos ajudar a aumentar
o conhecimento no país
e quando não estamos lá não são só eles
que ficam conosco temos em torno de 20 e
30 dos 40 pessoas nos acompanhando entre
residente estava a e as pessoas que
trabalham no hospital outros provedores
quando nós estamos a distância
continuamos acompanhando fazemos
teleconferências regulares e os últimos
casos apresentamos aulas e continuamos
interagindo com eles para preparar a
cada viagem levando em torno de quatro a
seis meses com encontros virtuais
regulares capulana acapo lana é um
tecido muito característico de
moçambique é um tecido que as mulheres
usam para cobrir o corpo ou usam como
uma saia ou usam nutron ou na cabeça
os recém-nascidos podem também ser
envolvidos pela capulana
as com as múltiplas cores e formas e
desenhos da capulana mostram a toda a
diversidade ea cultura do país e das
suas regiões e à riqueza que eles têm a
minha família anos já fizemos algumas
missões outros tipos de emissões em que
a gente foi no interior do estado aqui e
levamos em família amor pra outras
famílias
esse dia foi bem interessante ah eu
sempre com esse trabalho global a gente
acaba viajando bastante e eu sempre
comentava só não viaja em dia de
aniversário das minhas filhas
pois é mas um dia uma das viagens muito
próximo da data
tivemos que mudar a data e mudando a
data aconteceu também no dia do
aniversário de uma das minhas filhas e
eu disse então vou conversar com ela e
assim eu fiz
conversei a minha filha respondeu em
tudo bem desde que você volte logo para
nós comemorar nos juntas e disse filha
que lindo
tu sabes que nós estamos ajudando os
outros mas a gente fez uma combina eu
desisto pode escolher uma roupa minha e
colocar no dia do seu aniversário e
também escolheu uma roupa tua que eu vou
usar no dia do aniversário e assim ela
fez
claro que ela escolheu uma blusa mais
chocante mais rosa cheia de brilhos e eu
fui pro hospital com a blusa quase vira
celebridade todo mundo queria tirar foto
comigo naquele dia
e pra ela ficou a grande lição não é
esse filho nessa missão tu foste a maior
missionária emprestasse a tua mãe no dia
do seu aniversário para ajudar os outros
nós começamos a fazer também trabalhos
científicos lá em moçambique e começamos
com o trabalho para duas mil mulheres em
uma avaliação de prova de prevalência de
hpv que é um vírus relacionados ao
câncer que a gente trabalha e então a
gente conseguiu unir saúde consciência
mas os pacientes que têm lesões a gente
também precisa tratar e aí entra nos
nossos cursos de capacitação
então o que a gente faça um curso de
capacitação local para todos os
provedores que atendem aos pacientes e
fazendo todo esse atendimento então a
gente viu que é possível
a gente faça uma união entre ciência
saúde e sociedade porque a gente está
ajudando os pacientes daquela população
isso vai tomando sua estrutura natural e
vai crescendo e hoje não é só mais na
capital maputo que a gente faça esses
cursos de capacitação na última viagem
nós já fomos para uma outra cidade chama
beira e já temos programados mais quatro
regiões para os próximos dois anos aos
parceiros assim como o time importante
os parceiros também são muito
importantes
temos vários parceiros locais e temos
também parceiro em reston que chama a
este aniversário é uma universidade onde
os biomédicos e trabalham com a
professora rebecca robisch as cordas nos
ajudam e eles trabalham com o
desenvolvimento de novas tecnologias a
um dos principais trabalhos deles a
produzir equipamentos médicos
os mesmos que são usadas nos grandes
centros e nos países com mais recursos
para países com menos recursos
quando a gente vai para as missões a
parece que a gente leva bem pouquinho
mas a gente recebe bastante a gente
volta com o coração cheio de amor e
sempre missões uma experiência incrível
todos nós podemos tentar áfrica
moçambique um país na áfrica subsariana
acabar com o câncer de colo do útero é
uma doença evitável
nós temos que todos trabalhar no mesmo
caminho
e não é que a gente consegue unir a
ciência com a saúde ea sociedade
se cada um fizer o seu pouco nós
mudaremos o mundo às mudanças do mundo
são feitas por nós